make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Robin and
in this video I want to have a
conversation about magneto in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right because this is
something that a lot of people are
struggling with how to put magneto in
the MCU and it's kind of funny because
Marvel Comics already gave us a way to
do it in the story of secret Empire but
before we get into that this video is
sponsored by GI Joe war on Cobra so
whether you're a fan of the classic
animated movies the iconic toy line the
comics are all of the above
GI Joe war on Cobra has something for
everyone it has a massive roster
featuring the most beloved and infamous
heroes villains and vehicles that have
been featured over the course of the
entire series once you've chosen your
side in the game you'll be introduced to
the game's mechanics via roadblock for
GI Joe's or Baroness for Cobra once this
is done you'll learn how to manage your
base your units your vehicles and engage
in battles to help you get a feeling for
managing your troops and as you continue
with the single-player campaign missions
more options for reinforcing your army
with additional units heroes and
vehicles begin to open up but while
you're here I have a special in-game
gift from d3 go as a token of
appreciation for checking out GI Joe war
on Cobra I'm giving away two free
characters for all new players to help
reinforce your army and so as the Joe's
would say knowing is half the battle
check out the description down below to
download GI Joe war on Cobra and receive
your free gift for your mobile device so
having said all that magneto in the MCU
see here's the thing whenever people
talk about putting magneto in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they always kind of
seem to reference this idea that like
this his origin should be in line with
what it was in the comics and while
that's nice and everything the biggest
problem you have with that if the Marvel
Cinematic Universe follows more of a
real-time concept right we've talked
about that before the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is a blend between the ultimate
universe and earth 98 right where the
ultimate universe is the world outside
your window right like what our
superheroes existed like what if mobile
carriages existed right now what would
that look like out there in the world
and then earth 98 was an alternate
reality and model comics where
characters aged in real time you know
eventually the Fantastic Four got too
old to be superheroes they were
succeeded by new characters same with
spider-man and different things along
those lines
Thor actually aged all that kind of cool
stuff it was pretty cool but the problem
that you have
with magneto is if you were to say that
erik lensherr was a kid during the
events of world war ii and then
ultimately ended up surviving and then
basically exists now in the modern age
at least in the aftermath of Avengers in
game and infinity war then basically
that would make him like a hundred years
old and that's barely believable right
nobody's gonna believe that a 100 year
old guy is running around controlling
magnetism and just like whooping ass on
like you know all these different
characters that are out there things
like that that's not gonna work that's
kind of a benefit but kind of the
drawback of magneto right because his
origin is super cool right if you guys
ever get a chance go check out magneto
testament it's one of the coolest
origins right it was written by Greg Pak
and it gives us like this full-on origin
origin story for era clincher going into
women and he basically became magneto
right you go from there into like
classic x-men issue well I think it is
but it basically runs over the the
original origin by Chris Claremont of
magneto it's cool right it's an
interesting idea but again you can't
really have a 100 year-old magneto well
then people would counter with that and
they would say well what about some kind
of explanation
we're like mutants aged slower than
humans right or like you know he was
somehow frozen and ice or something like
that like Captain America but the
problem that you went into with that is
it becomes hand wavy it's like okay so
like we've got a character that we want
to introduce him to the MCU but they
would be really old at the time that
they were introduced if we follow their
actual Marvel Comics continuity so we'll
just say they're frozen in ice it worked
for Captain America in magneto it'll
work here too right you know where they
just aged really slow or something like
that and that could work for a couple
characters right and you know really
slow aging can work for a like Wolverine
or it can work for Sabretooth or it can
work for anybody else who is part of the
webinar to has a healing factor it's
like Deadpool different people like that
but the fact remains you can't use that
all the time right and I think that's
really result of people who want to see
magneto in the MCU but they don't want
to see his character's origin change and
something's gotta give right you can't
have it both ways because it just
doesn't work that way and so so you know
in thinking about that my idea was how
do we get him in there right like how do
you put magneto in the MCU but then it
sort of getting into like these you know
real-world situations and and trying to
tie all that stuff in and it's like the
why though right because we've got one
built in with sokovia and the funny
thing about it is that in in a Marvel
Cinematic Universe sokovia is largely
unexplored there really isn't a whole
lot that we know about sokovia always we
know is that like it's there and like
that's where Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch came from and that's it however we
did get an explanation in the
Captain America Steve Rogers stories
from an expense or that was part of
'secret empire now here's the thing the
secret Empire was a story that a lot of
people liked but a lot of people
disliked ah it really kind of split you
know Captain America fans I loved it I
thought it was an amazing story didn't
really care for the ending too much the
ending was I think kind of plan to the
last minute but I love the story for
what it was right the idea that Captain
America has basically been part of Hydra
this entire time but in terms of getting
an explanation on sokovia this came in
Captain America Steve Rogers issue
number seven and what we ended up
learning was that sokovia was
essentially part of the Eastern Bloc
right and so the Eastern Bloc were
basically countries that were part of
the Warsaw Pact that was signed by the
various members of the Soviet Union as
an antithesis to NATO and so the result
of that is that when the Soviet Union
fell a lot of these these countries that
were previously part of the Soviet Union
or just basically loved without any real
centralized government right whatever
kind of governors or stewards or what
have you you know who were basically
running the show at that point in time
they were the ones that kind of kept
running things or sometimes there were
no governments at all right it was just
kind of like capitalism yeah we got rid
of communism
good luck Eastern Bloc you got this
buddy that was basically yet that was
the response the United States for the
most part right and so as a result of
that with sokovia itself at least in in
terms of this Captain America story the
way you ended up seeing was the rise of
a guy by the name of Camille Nevada he
was basically a former Russian general
or or Soviet general who essentially
took totalitarian control of sokovia and
started implementing all these insane
human rights violations and he was
nicknamed the butcher now around this
point in time what ended up happening is
Hydra stepped in and Hydra stepped in as
kind of like hey guys were here as
liberators when in reality they weren't
there were kind of manipulating things
but essentially they kind of took over
they ended up seeing him Elstad Red
Skull ended up you know taking over
sokovia so on and so forth and that was
basically it
but these significance of this and the
reason why it matters is because if the
Marvel Cinematic Universe were to take
that notion of sokovia from Marvel
Comics and then modify it a bit and
throw it into the MCU and then in turn
give us Magneto
it works perfect it works absolutely
perfect and all you have to do is just
say that magneto was like a younger boy
when essentially the Eastern Bloc fell
in sokovia like so many other countries
were just kind of left flying by the
seat of their pants and so he ended up
witnessing firsthand these atrocities of
Camille niveau Dee right I ended up
seeing these things going down and then
in turn realized how screwed up humanity
could be along the way you can throw in
some things like there were individuals
with power
started popping up and then you really
kind of turned this into essentially the
winter guard and you just transfer it
transform it into what was going on to
sokovia right so if the way that's
played out in terms of the winter guard
to offer some explanation here in
Louisville Comics the winter guard was
essentially Russia's answer to the
Avengers but the reason why this
mattered is because at the time when the
Avengers first popped up Russia didn't
really know how to deal with it and so
what Russia ended up doing was basically
sending various soldiers around the
country and then rounding up everyone
who had superpowers and then they were
simply going to force them to fight on
behalf of the Soviet government what
this did is it basically led to the
attempted roundup of guys like Colossus
Colossus was ultimately rescued by
Charles Xavier and then brought to the
States
to fight alongside really the third
iteration of the x-men the yeah deadly
Genesis really kind of introduced the
second team that we didn't know about
the secret x-men team that nobody knew
about
like Vulcan missile mega level mutant
and and and so on and so forth but the
fact remains that the winter guard ended
up ended up forming out of Russia's
response to the Avengers in the midst of
the Cold War yes that's what you
basically do here you say that what what
you know Camille nobody had basically
discovered is that there were
individuals in his country that had
powers what the origins all those powers
were he didn't know he didn't care all
he knew was that they had abilities and
they could be used to bolster the power
of his army because maybe he wanted to
rise to prominence and have a place on
the world stage like so many petty
dictators are looking for and so as a
result of that he ended up rounding up
various individuals of superpowers well
in turn
magneto Erik Lehnsherr at a young age
saw this and saw the experiments were
being conducted so on so forth and that
goes into the whole idea of when
humanity comes across individuals with
powers either they're destroyed or
they're exploited and it totally warps
and skews his perspective on humanity
and then of course you end up having the
events of Avengers showing up they're
not doing sokovia any favours and it's
kind of like enough is enough
right so what you basically do is you
say he was there in sokovia from the
time that the Eastern Bloc fell all the
way up until the events of Avengers age
of Ultron and watched as everything
unfolded and slowly began to lose faith
in humanity and began to come to the
realization that mutants being what they
are would either be captured by humanity
and use for their own ends or destroyed
if humanity couldn't find a means to
contain and control it and so in turn he
ends up becoming more of like a mutant
extremists right he's not really a good
guy not really a bad guy he's just a guy
who believes that that mutants deserve
their own place in the world and he'll
force humanity to give them that by any
means necessary right so I think it's a
cool notion right now again this is
napkin stuff right this is me thing is
the thing
in the span of like 15 minutes right so
this is off-the-cuff probably deserves a
little more planning and a little more
looking into in terms of organizing this
pop but I think just you know for first
a napkin math you know essentially I
think it works right I think it kind of
comes together pretty well so let me
know what you guys think you know let me
know how you guys feel about this and
let me know if there's changes you guys
would make to this whole idea right
because I love your all's input I love
hearing what you guys have to say about
this kind of stuff so if you guys are
new here too comments explain to make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb cork you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
white and I will catch you all later
Bruce
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]